[Music]
george is in new york city to start off
this hour hey george what's up
hey how are you it's great to talk with
you you too man how can i help
i'm calling because i'm struggling with
figuring out how to balance growing a
business i recently started while also
doing a lot of the home care with my two
young children and the third kid on the
way
and probably needing to pay for some
child care i'm trying to get out of
about 225 000 of debt with my wife and
we're we're having a hard time figuring
out how to do that quickly and
efficiently with um without
my having more time to grow the business
okay
what kind of debt
a lot of student loan debt a lot of uh
mistakes and uh paying way too much for
school i'm a psychologist and i spent
over three hundred thousand dollars to
become a psychologist um
and uh so uh i think you say a lot of
stupid uh i've heard you say before
yeah what's your business you open a
practice uh so
i did i i for a long time was gonna do
the public service loan forgiveness but
uh you you are a part of my inspiration
to decide not to do that and uh to pay
back what i borrowed i paid back my wife
and i have paid back over a hundred
thousand dollars of that so far and we
have 225 left
well we inspire people to pay back what
you owe for one thing but it's also
important that we also give you
information the student loan forgiveness
is a complete fraud that only 4 000
people have actually gotten it while
almost 300 000 have applied for it so we
need to keep that in mind it wasn't
going to work so there's that but yeah
so way to go man you got a bot like you
got a lot of balls in there you're a
busy man
uh that's i appreciate you saying that
because it sure feels like it how's the
business doing
uh it's been fantastic thank you i feel
very fortunate that i've been able to do
that and without knowing much about
ken's proximity principle uh that's kind
of how i grew it and did it slowly and
then took a
small step instead of a big leap and
it's doing very well i'm very happy with
it i'd like to help grow it to be able
to pay off the debt faster but with
myself my doing a lot of cooking doing a
lot of picking up kids and getting here
to there i feel like i only have so much
time and
okay because you know and why are you
doing all the child care
my wife also works
she's a school teacher and she provides
us our health benefits and uh she's an
amazing woman and i appreciate
everything she does but with the
flexibility i have with my my schedule
that's where i'm kind of picking up and
so
that's where the dilemma is
okay what will your business make this
year
uh revenue just the last at this last
year was just under 300 000 and what
does she make teaching school
she takes home uh
she makes a little over 70 uh she takes
home okay so the guy the person making
300 guy argyle
is taking time off from making 300
because the person making 70 doesn't
have time
correct
yeah that's real sweet but it's stupid
it's real nurturing but it's
economically stupid and it's part of why
you're stressed i mean
and she's also pregnant you said
and she we just found out we have our
third child on the way just found out
okay so first trimester awesome man it's
exciting hey listen here's the thing
uh none
you know
none of this lasts forever
and so when you're burning the candle at
both ends as long as it is not a 10-year
prescription you can get away with it
but you can't get away with it if
there's no hope that it's going to end
okay and christy wright talks about in
the book we did with her called take
back your time that balance is not doing
an equal amount of everything balance is
doing the right things
at the right time and so in this season
that you're in
you've got to decide here's what we're
going to do
and in the next season we're going to do
x let me give an example okay i'm just
making this up this would happen at the
ramsey house as an example
we're old school though i'll warn you
ahead of time all right
um
sharon in the first trimester would take
on more of the kids stuff and i'd i
would pour the i put the wood on the
fire over at work by the time she gets
the third trimester she's gonna need
some relief
for sure and working okay and so yeah
you're gonna have to dial back work then
and step in as super dad again
but super dad right now
yeah
maybe not
maybe not maybe maybe your version of
super dad right now is you throw wood on
the fire and get some is paid down and
then when the baby comes you're probably
going to slow down a little bit too
because she's got three and she's gonna
be uh you know recovering from delivery
and so you got about six you got about
nine months about the last three months
of pregnancy plus the next the first six
months of the new baby that you're gonna
be in super dad mode and so you gotta
turn it back and turn it turn it on turn
it off a little bit
um and just go this is for this season
and you two sit down talk about it
together she may not be willing to do
that but that's what sharon would do
and she would be going listen matter of
fact she would kick my butt out and go
get go get the work done you're the one
making money
she didn't have any tolerance for
i mean we had rachel the year we filed
bankruptcy so i kind of stopped by the
hospital saw the baby went back to work
you know i mean it really wasn't like
rachel doesn't remember that yeah it
didn't affect rachel at all i mean
sharon but sharon's like old school
she's like what are you doing here
you're supposed to be working we need
money
so uh yeah but that's uh uh but it's a
temporary thing i wasn't an absentee dad
the entire time my children were there
but i really when i was starting the
business there was a time there was a
season
that i poured on the wood and then
there's a season that you have to be
there as a dad more so like to help your
wife and these things and there's a
season she has to help yeah and
it's back and forth and back and forth
and then there's also a season where
it's just freaking crazy
and it's just not forever and we can
hold on by the skin of our teeth and
just grit our teeth and push through it
yeah i mean you guys are making 370
grand there's no reason you can't get
some child care get some help here so
that you can focus on work because
you're going to make more than you would
have if you were staying home taking
care of the kids versus putting them in
some kind of child care for this season
like dave saying and you can pay this
off in under two years with your income
this is easily possible but it feels
like a lot right now when you're
juggling it all at once but her third
turn my trimester through the first six
months of the third child being born
your business is going to suffer because
you need to be there with your family
but this during the next six months um
your family is gonna they're gonna you
have to make some other adjustments
maybe i don't know that's one way you
could look at it the point being
if you'll take the pressure off of
trying to be everything to everyone all
the time and say okay for this season
we're gonna do this for this season
we're gonna do that for that season
we're gonna do this and then by the time
when all this is over here's what it's
gonna look like and we get to go to
disney you know
and or whatever it is you all do to
celebrate i didn't go to disney
celebrate but i did take the kids one
time after i was gone 60 days on a book
tour there we go that was a season i was
gone
128 media stops all over the united
states i was gone but it was the number
one got the got the career launched got
the book launched came home took the
kids to disney that's what they remember
don't they just stay they don't put any
noise gone